[Music]
and dr. debunk news oh I thought they
were gonna stop at dr. D I wish
submitted by Pierre Tirico loves JK
aren't they [ __ ] from the hurricane
that's what this is it's not oh yeah you
just went there did the hurricane [ __ ]
it up
they Verde like they fix everything up
the pine see like don't look to the left
let this [ __ ] up over there they
looked over to the right you know
resorts are always somehow ok
hello well you saw the put equals n put
across the ridge that still shut down
oh really yeah because it's on the left
are they called Polly Klaas because
they're Brooklyn Porto Ricans oh I
didn't think of that
I don't know everybody goes I don't know
Radhika well I just said I cuz I heard a
party gwah I never heard a portico I
just made that up
because there's a male version what do
you when I'm saying it so much stuff not
just were tokens they are cool body
they're just Porto Rican girls she
brought up a good thing where it's like
it could have been Brooklyn but it comes
up boutique Wow
educators the Asian thing you would ever
know in the comments like you guys don't
know [ __ ] anyway so just keep going it's
body mornin
oh it's more than a yeah American you
made that [ __ ] Spanish word son so
Korean boricua what poor lacroix Paulo
she doesn't know if she said it back to
you what song is it meanest guy one yep
the name of it poor no no
no no that's another one you're thinking
of something bad Joe that's what I'm
talking about
that's I'm I think no there's not two
songs like that we make Oh remix of the
same song is it yeah yeah Nina sky1 a
doctor cracked his own knuckles for
sixty years to prove it doesn't cause
arthritis really I love that that's
awesome because I'm thinking of it
because there's all right submit it I do
it you could crack your knuckles all day
but it doesn't it doesn't crying do it
I always crack my knuckles I feel so
good yeah it does real son I can't crack
my knuckles it doesn't crack I have my
neck like this I love sometimes I do
this and it cracks you do this where you
put some distance between your knees and
then you flex your butt cheeks and then
your spine card what are you kidding me
but your ass is like a [ __ ] sign
muscle brother did it crack did you so
like you go like this and you press your
knees and your knuckles together like
this and then you squeeze your ass
cheeks how did you figure that out
I forgot it but I felt good no wait
squeeze your ass cheeks together [ __ ]
you make me forget idiot not
appreciative okay
yes so this doctor he practice had like
only one hand for 60 years just to prove
it doesn't cause I'm what a gamble huh
yeah cuz he would have just been like so
what causes arthritis that my mom has
our
is not getting enough nutrients it's
like overuse right and not enough
recovery mmm
I don't know let me google it cuz I I
was just looking at crack knuckles stuff
let me see people who type with a
computer all day that's like carpal
tunnel why you get our 32nd what's the
difference between carpal tunnel and
arthritis yeah cause different okay so
different types of arthritis exists each
with different causes including wear and
tear infections and underlying diseases
symptoms include pain swelling reduced
range of motion and stiffness Wow
painful inflammation and stiffness in
the joints a smoke we for the arthritis
oh man I should get my mom hi yeah let's
get your mom hi and hide her keys
this doesn't go home oh I see you've
been trying to convince no trying to get
her moving for long the guest house yeah
oh yeah but guest house we want to you
said you found the house with all of
your needs they didn't have a guest
house right now it's a guest room but it
has also big enough where she could have
her own side of the thing it's because
she hopes I don't want her [ __ ] ghost
is like I'm going home and I'm always
that you're going upstairs dude I would
love if your mom lived in a guest house
via kids be tight hell yeah well your
mom takes care of you guys good
my mom's like a genius yeah what did you
do Smee but she left so fast cuz I saw a
woman that looked just like you yeah
that's my memo was it like Steve but
with long hair no like they had the same
eyes yeah yeah he looks like exactly a
combination of his mom and dad mm-hmm
yeah it looks exactly like him too I was
too focused on the lesbian this is his
mom right here and then the rest is his
debt oh it's weird it's so funny
Nicky looks like a dad I [ __ ] love it
Oh combination
you look nothing like your mother yes I
do
Oh like a dad what part of hers or mama
and I'm not cool like your nose it's
like yeah my my nose up is my mom and my
nose down is my dad your even have a
combination is your dad cuz my my dad's
got a Filipino nose it's like this
and then she's got a Russian nose it's
like this and I have like an in-between
nose it's like kind of pointy kind of
your motivation yeah she was she's it's
French German Russian yeah so your mom
looks more German without Russian to me
her her maiden name was Garst
first it's German yeah this German let
her my great-grandma was from Russia oh
yeah all right so yeah this doctor here
do you guys want to see ya at Chuck E
Cheese birthday no he's so happy when
you got just through looks like he
gambled a gamble for 60 years I like it
or is it in the back wait till I'm a
[ __ ] geezer I'm a dress like that it's
a foam dice on it oh you guys gonna wear
geezer clothes yeah wear suits and
spenders and - they're not gonna be keys
are close to us those there's gonna be
that outfit man you're older and then
everyone's like oh that's what they used
to wear in 2008 because if you look at
how they used to dress and they were
younger it's think it did well let me
wear and forties no more none I didn't
say you weren't allowed to wear them I
said really look styling weird dad
shirts up and down that's not true how
many compliments you get now versus
before you guys are all in on it
together like get some fries he's the
one that said you want a dress that says
you're so important and we talked about
you when we [ __ ] get together Steve
does like nicer thing that's our point
he's the one that told me he wanted me
to help him pick out clothes cuz he
wanted my identity you lost your
identity ID no more man
okay go change into graphic shirt I will
sometimes it's easier where you don't
have to think and you grab clothes and
they all match yeah like but they all
match if you're doing solid colors on
colors that's true have you just
what's that with jeans is fine but it
takes brainpower when you're not used to
it what no it doesn't if your whole out
if your whole closet is nothing but the
whole shirt or don't button it you wear
like a white shirt under [ __ ] Henley
shirt - yeah right hand lean do you guys
ever want to get laid like we give you
guys so many tips why you think Mark
Zuckerberg wears the same [ __ ] every day
because he's copying Steve Jobs Steve
Jobs does you sound like one of the
people in our team his copies he does
I've never even thought of that
yeah you use some wannabe yeah that's so
true yep they were the same clothes
every day will they do it because they
don't want they think that taking that
decision out of the mix look opens their
brain for other thing that's why I have
a color every day taste the decision out
of it Oh
today's yellow yeah and I have very few
guys so she was she's she's worried
about Tim's wedding because she has to
wear nice worried I have a lot of Navy
clothes but it's just the one that they
liked was pink dress yeah I showed them
to Navy options and one pink option are
you guys gonna wear a suit yeah I would
just wear the same [ __ ] I wore at a tips
wedding I got to make use of that suit
well I thought you were supposed to the
suits are fur but you just change the
dress shirts I hope so what suit is it
it's gray oh cool oh that's perfect for
an aide for wigs have a gray suit too
here's a gray suit - mm-hmm but I don't
know if I might do black inside or the
white inside I think it's a dark Ari
I like the black meat too cause it feels
gangster yeah look are you gonna wear
the 9-mil with this suit or the 45 at
the suit with your lady salmon it's pink
so you can wear dark or light
they either wine would match fashion
tips by Nikki
yeah what about a graphic tee underneath
the suit nope Yeah right like I'm Jack
nope this shirt is [ __ ]
get one of those tuxedo shirts yeah I
bet no one's ever done that before
can you do that can we do that if it
comes on down time Tim's weddings like
around the corner yeah anyway do you
guys know why your fingers crack when
you crack them yes it's the nitrogen gas
you you're releasing missing air
nitrogen scientists don't they can't
they can't really decide on whether it's
the
forming of air bubbles or the bubbles
bursting they can't really decide which
one it is
it's whether one or the other but they
did do this MRI one where they're saying
don't burst into me I think it's like
when you open the Tupperware and it's
like you know yeah no then what is the
Ergo when you crack it out of your butt
[Laughter]
burnt bit or farted out it is like the
ligament Lera yeah I don't know that's
it's interesting cuz it's like a balloon
you know it's like yeah it's your skin's
like a balloon and it just cracks and a
nickels in your body still I mean your
body gets oxygen anyway yeah yeah
norville fluid that inertia already
overloading my brain it's this fluid
that's creating bubbles in your joints I
like that explanation better yeah so
there's this fluid that's in there that
causes your joints to not like rush up
against each other all right
feels good when my spine in the morning
when I go yeah and I feel loose is it
psychological or is it really loosing it
up it does feel loose no it feels looser
yeah cuz you're always high and if I cut
my neck all the time
we did this same motion but didn't crack
anything yes you are stretching your
satisfying yeah right but when you crack
you just follow it feels like you've
farted feels like a song yeah like bone
farts and like big point fight your
feels come to this event title enjoy
farting farts now that's clever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]